[موسيقى]
لقد حذر الحوثيون مؤخرا من اندلاع مواجهه
مع التحالف في على الجبهه البحريه
اليمنيه سيكون اولويتهم في المرحله
المقبله
الاقليميه ومن الجدير بالذكر هنا انه من
غير المرشح ان يقوم الحوثيون بمهاجمه
السفن غير المنخرطه في النزاع او تلك التي
تحاول تصدير النفقه من الموانئ التي لا
يسيطرون عليها ومع ذلك يبقى احتمال ارتكاب
الخطا في تحدي هويه السفن والاخطاء
الحسابيه قائمه
[موسيقى]
بين الحوثيون اجر مؤخرا اختبارات اطلاق
الصواريخ من صنعاء هبطت في المياه الدوليه
والحوثيون معروفون باستخدامهم تشكيله
واسعه من المسيرات الجويه والبحريه
فالتهديد قد يكون مصدره اي من المصادر
اعلاه
[موسيقى]
وتركز هذه القوه على الامن البحري
الاقليمي وبناء القدرات من خلال بناء
الشركه مع القوه البحريه وفر السواحل
التابعه لدول المنطقه لتحسين مشاركه
المعلومات والتنسيق فهذه القوه جلبت معها
من سفينتين الى ثمان سفن ومسيره بحريه
جويه مما يزيد من الوجود العسكري في
المنطقه ويحسن الذرايه بالاوضاع وقدره
الاستجابه في حال وقوع حادث
[موسيقى]